[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the previous episode of
"Android Testing Patterns,"
you learned the basic Espresso
test flow, finding a view,
performing an action,
and verifying the result.
Things get a little
more complicated
when testing a screen that
contains a ListView, which
can be backed by an adapter with
tens or even hundreds of rows.
Most of the time, the view
that you are interested in
might not even be on the
screen, as AdapterViews only
show a small number of children,
and recycle child views
as you scroll.
Fortunately, Espresso already
comes with a solution.
Instead of using
the onView method,
start your search with
onData, and provide a matcher
against the data that is backing
the view you'd like to match.
Espresso will do all
the legwork of finding
the row in the adapter and
bringing it into the viewport.
Let's look at an example.
I'll clone our testing samples
repository from GitHub,
and open the Espresso
DataAdapterSample.
Here, we have a simple activity
showing a ListView populated
with 100 items.
The ListView is backed
by a simple adapter
where each row is a collection
of key value pairs stored
as a Map.
I'll switch to the
Test class now.
You can see onData
and the helper method
that is used throughout
the test to locate
a row in the ListView.
hasEntry is a standard
hamcrest matcher
designed to work with Maps.
Here, we're using it to
search for rows whose text is
equal to the given argument.
If I go ahead and run
the tests in this class,
you can see that Espresso
is scrolling the ListView
to the desired position before
performing actions on the rows.
If your AdapterView items
are not Map instances,
you can, of course, use
other measures in onData.
Just make sure you know
what type of objects
your adapter is holding.
If you are using
a CursorAdapter,
there are convenient matchers
available in the CursorMatchers
class.
There is one more case I want to
cover, and that's RecyclerView.
Although it works on a similar
principle as AdapterViews,
it does not actually inherit
from the AdapterView class.
There's a separate
set of methods
to work with RecyclerViews
that let you scroll
and perform actions
on its child views.
If you want to see more examples
of working with views backed
by adapters, check
out my article
in "Medium," linked
in the description.
Happy testing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]